there is just more and more information
coming out on how the government
coordinated to silence people related to
covet so a journalist by the name of
David zweig he had a really long
extensive Twitter threat on on what's
going on here with the government and
big Tech I'm going to just read you
portions of it it was like a 30 tweet
long thread so we just picked some of
the highlights here the Twitter files
how Twitter rigged the covid debate here
we go by censoring info that was true
but inconvenient to US policy so here
are the highlights first by discrediting
doctors and other experts who disagreed
by suppressing ordinary users including
some sharing the CD scenes the cdc's own
data the United States government
pressured Twitter and other social media
platforms to elevate certain content and
suppress other content about covid-19 it
wasn't just Twitter the meetings with
the Trump White House were also attended
by Google Facebook Microsoft and others
so let's just be clear this was the
Trump White house do when the Biden
Administration took over one of their
first meeting requests with Twitter
Executives was on covid the focus was on
anti-vaxxer accounts especially Alex
Berenson in the summer of 2021 President
Biden said social media companies were
killing people for allowing vaccine
misinformation Berenson was suspended
hours after Biden's comments and kicked
off the platform the following month but
Twitter did suppress views many from
doctors and scientific experts that
conflicted with the official positions
of the White House as a result
legitimate findings and questions that
would have expanded the public debate
went missing inevitably dissent yet
legitimate content was labeled as
misinformation and the accounts of
doctors and others were suspended both
for tweeting opinions and demonstrably
true information
exhibit a Dr Martin koldorf an
epidemiologist at Harvard Medical School
tweeted views at odds with U.S Public
Health authorities and the American left
the political affiliation of nearly the
entire staff at Twitter No thinking that
everyone must be vaccinated is as
scientifically flawed as thinking that
nobody should coveted vaccines are
important for older high-risk people and
their caretakers those with prior
natural infection do not need it nor
children
internal emails show an intent to action
by a moderator saying koldorf's tweet
violated the company's covid-19
misinformation policy and claimed he
shared false information after Twitter
took action koldor's tweet was slapped
with a misleading label and all replies
and likes were shut off throttling the
tweet's ability to be seen and shared by
many people the ostensible core function
of the platform okay then of course what
you know the the post-mortem of this is
that Elon Musk eventually buys Twitter
Alex berensen is back on Twitter Dr
Robert Malone and Dr Peter McCullough
are back on Twitter uh he is
systematically right now Elon Musk
getting rid of the content moderation
teams at Twitter he fired a whole bunch
more people just this past weekend who
were in charge of silencing people but
the fact is you really just need to know
this guys it kind of sucks to know
because it puts us in one of those
dystopia Ian Schwarzenegger movies from
the 80s the government without question
was pressuring social media companies to
silence you
[Music]